who could replace Dana White I've asked
this question from quite a few different
people just curious you know what's your
thoughts on this man I don't think I
mean everybody
said Daniel Cormier he said Daniel
couldn't do my job but who do you think
could replace I don't think nobody can
replace Dana White I don't think so I
mean to do to be as good as they know
what it was I think some someone can
come and fill the hole
maybe not be like Dana White be better
at certain things that Dana White maybe
sometimes Dino white is not very
diplomatic so it could be
it could be more diplomatic but maybe to
to be a promoter to to be intense as as
unique as Dana White is only one guy is
Dana White it doesn't mean his job
cannot be taken and he cannot be run
place I think everybody can be run place
but nobody everybody is unique and
everybody has a different unique
personality